all right here we are the finale that
half the internet's been looking forward
to before we get started i want to thank
the sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by nordvpn nordvpn's a
vpn service that looks to be more than
just a vpn service they look to help
make your experience on the trash fire
known as the internet a little more
palatable a little more comfortable not
only can you change your virtual
location with one click allowing you to
view content that might not be available
in your location but with nord security
bundle you also get advanced protection
scanned downloaded files for viruses
malware protection notifications and
let's not posture we've all been there
reformatting because of a virus it's no
fun do not let the device that your
life's information is on become a
cautionary tale and all this is under
north's 30-day money-back guarantee
which means no risk and reward you know
i love that so click the link below go
to nordvpn.com
john's get yourself a two-year plan at a
huge discount plus one additional month
for free and now the obi-wan kenobi
finale has aired which means my saga of
videos
is pleasing
neither side of the internet finally
comes to an end in the finale of obi-wan
kenobi really there are two story lines
happening here two things are happening
rivas found out about this boy on
tatooine living with owen because bale
organa apparently is the only politician
who doesn't know the concept of not
leaving evidence on an answering machine
and obi-wan goes down on this planet as
darth vader's star destroyer is
following the ship he's like i'll lure
darth vader away so you'll all live and
darth vader goes down to meet him and
now we have what the star wars twitter
was what were they saying rematch of the
century i was like that was the rematch
of the century really but there is a
part that happens at the end of that
fight which is my favorite part in the
entire series of obi-wan kenobi so i'm
gonna save that for a little later it's
okay reeva finding out about this kid
which i mean that's a leap though you
gotta admit that all she got from this
hologram message from bail organa was
you can't find out about the children
tell them owen the boy it's just like
okay obi-wan and bail organa are hiding
this kid on tatooine's living with owen
i know owen we i ran into him this is
one of those things this show actually
has done this a few times it's kind of
like when you get the flashback with
riva and anakin skywalker stabs her
through the stomach and kills her
friends and riva's like anakin's clearly
darth vader but they don't look anything
alike and they don't share the same name
and i was like how did she how did she
know that though and those were the
responses in the comment section people
were like well clearly the clone
troopers called him lord vader and they
probably did but the show didn't show
that it didn't illustrate that it's like
the obi-wan series does that a lot it's
just like all right well leaps are being
made but you get it you can piece it
together fine i suppose the same could
be said about riva making that leap of
like huh bail organa and obi-wan kenobi
are hiding a kid with owen on tatooine
clearly that's my sith lord boss's son
how did she get there would have been
funny if she had gone the more logical
route when she showed up to owen's place
imagine her just plopping down like i
know about the kid and i know the truth
sailor ghana clearly had a kid with
someone on tatooine and obi wan's
helping him to cover it up and hide him
so bail organic can avoid political
scandal paying child support divorce
that's clearly what's happening i mean
of the leap she could make i feel like
that's more logical than this kid is
clearly my sith lord boss's son anyhow i
guess we just assumed that she made the
connection between luke and anakin
skywalker and now she's arrived to kill
luke which she doesn't really do which
is fair like me a good arc when
someone's about to do a terrible thing
they're like i guess that's not in me i
guess i'm not that bad i'm free from
being under vader's rule i can choose my
own destiny choose my own life i choose
to be good i guess i draw the line here
i kind of see it as the martha thing in
batman vs superman i get how the
connection was made but i'm still like i
mean
so that's it this show generally changed
how i see inquisitors not for the better
i always assumed like inquisitors were
on the inside with vader you know they
were clearly terrible people i assume
vader already had her do things that are
about as bad as killing children because
you know she's an inquisitor and vader
has to know that she will take those
steps and make those decisions so the
fact that she's like no i'm not going to
kill this kid i don't know
i assumed she had already killed
children tied up in a bit of a nice neat
little bow i don't know how obi-wan's
sleeping well at night generally this
show ended on all right everyone's in a
good place kind of way i don't know how
obi wan is like there's an ex-inquisitor
out there who seems to you know seems to
be on a good path now don't know if
she's still on the revenge path with
vader and revenge is the path to the
dark side so she could
go back to the dark side and she knows
about luke and i'm just not sleeping
well at night like how does he sleep
well at night that would give me anxiety
for the next seven to ten years before a
new hope i just all right also riva
looks pretty good for someone who is
just stabbed with a lightsaber in a
world where there's no reason to think
her internal organs and her spine
weren't going through exactly what that
door was going through this is going by
that she's walking around next episode
and neither does he so the darth vader
obi-wan fight the bummer with this
entire concept of darth vader and
obi-wan kenobi coming face to face as
they did in the ob1 series is the series
officially doesn't justify its own
existence like i was very resistant to
an obi-wan series when i first heard the
concept of it or was going to be a movie
back in 2017 i think i first heard like
they're going to do this thing strong
possibility anyway and i was like no i
don't want them to come face to face i
don't want them to fight i like their
first meeting after revenge of the sith
being in a new hope
but
there is that one line in return of the
jedi where luke's talking to vader and
he's like come with me father they're
still good in you i feel it and vader
says obi-wan wants thought as you do you
don't know the power of the dark side i
must obey my master i always liked that
line but that it always left me wanting
in terms of the whole saga
i always felt like there was something i
didn't see because obi-wan didn't say
that in revenge of the sith he was like
i would do what i must cause all right
you came to kill him even padme was like
you're going to kill him aren't you
that's why he goes to mustafar he
doesn't give him a lecture he doesn't
say come with me they're still good in
you anything like that i also liked that
scene in return of the jedi because that
was the first time i ever felt like
vader felt like a prisoner of his own
actions but that dialogue between
obi-wan and vader of come with me
they're still good in you never happens
in this show it's like oh the one thing
that hooked me into a concept or a
possibility of an obi-wan series
it doesn't happen it's the obi-wan
invader fight in a fight that's not
nearly as good as the fight that's in
revenge of the sith i'm not talking
about the concept of all right now you
have a guy who's 10 years later and he's
rusty with the force and a cyborg so
he's clearly not going to be as good
you're comparing that to two jedi in
their prime or jedi in a new sith lord
no i'm saying like in terms of the shaky
cam and the choreography i just felt it
fell short also i felt it was dumb that
obi-wan was ever rusty with the force he
had one job and that was to be prepared
to train luke when the time came he's
like all right
i guess i'll just not keep up on the
force but oh shoot now this guy who's
rusty with the force forces fighting
vader who's clearly a powerhouse with
the force so they need this one
throwaway line when obi-wan's fighting
vader or vader's like your powers have
returned i'm like oh that's it i guess i
feel like there's no continuity in this
universe but the best part of the fight
the episode and the series as a whole is
when obi-wan slashes vader's mask and
you basically it's the same
same energy as they say as that scene in
rebels when ahsoka does the same thing
and the reason i love this scene in here
because it does a lot
to
basically annex the characters of anakin
skywalker and darth vader into a
character that feels like the same
character i mean we know they're the
same character but you look at that
scene in rebels and you're like that is
anakin skywalker from clone wars but
he's darth vader now it feels like the
same character i'm glad the same thing
happened with live action here i'm glad
we got half of the hayden christensen
burned face you hear half of his voice
half of vader's voice when he's talking
to obi-wan says i'm not your failure you
didn't kill anakin skywalker i did i was
like damn that's good [ __ ] it's so good
in fact i didn't need the five and a
half episodes leading up to this scene
this could have been a fan film for all
i cared just one fan film obi-wan
invader on this planet and they fight
and he slashes his mask and they have
this dialogue ewan mcgregor sells it as
well i thought ewan mcgregor and hayden
christensen face to face
face to half face how to phrase it a
couple minutes of that dialogue
was
what i liked about the show most
really what sticks with me from the show
at all and i do like that at the end we
get themes you know when vader's talking
to the emperor you get the imperial
theme there you get leia's theme when
obi-wan drops leia off back with the
organas you get the skywalker theme like
the star wars themes have finally shown
up in the obi-wan series and they did
wonders the importance of music and
musical themes cannot be overstated my
friends music is a discovery it's not an
invention it resonates with us as humans
on a very personal level those john
williams themes are a part of star wars
they're a part of star wars a very
intimate degree i don't know why they
didn't use them more in the series like
there are disney star wars things out
there i can see why those classic themes
aren't used because they are news
stories but in a series where you have
owen baroo luke obi-wan vader leia the
organist like those themes should have
been used more in the end the obi-wan
series like every episode has at least a
scene where i was like that was a pretty
cool scene you know i enjoyed that scene
there are at least scenes i can be like
well they're the best part of the
episode which really isn't fair to say
because every episode's gonna have
something that is the best part even if
all of it falls short but it's a series
that never justifies its own existence
at the very end obi-wan kenobi finally
sees qui-gon jinn's force ghost and it's
liam neeson and they kind of write off
in the sunset together very
happy-go-lucky and the thing i was
thinking i was like you made up this
whole story to bring obi-wan back to the
place he was at the end of revenge of
the sith at the end of revenge of the
sith he gets done fighting vader and now
he's going to recluse on tatooine
training with qui-gon's force ghost and
at the beginning of the obi-wan series
apparently obi-wan doesn't know that
darth vader is alive out there he has
not been training with qui-gon's force
ghost then he goes gallivanting on this
whole adventure in the galaxy and he
comes back to a place where he just got
done fighting darth vader he's going to
recluse on tatooine and train with
qui-gon's force goes the biggest thing i
have to say is the obi-wan series should
have been two different shows it's kind
of baffling it wasn't it's like disney's
they're the kings of optimizing how many
shows they can bleed from one concept
they could have had an inquisitor series
and an obi-wan series but instead they
were like nah we'll just crush them into
one and get half the views the
inquisitor series about riva there's an
interesting story to be told there the
story of this former jedi padawan who
survives order 66 and becomes an
inquisitor to get in with vader so she
can get close to vader to kill vader
dude that a show or a movie like that
that could be like gangs of new york in
star wars only instead of dicaprio and
bill the butcher you have riva and darth
vader that could be awesome and an
obi-wan series which i would say an
obi-wan movie should have been a much
more personal story if you read the
description of the finale episode of the
obi-wan series it says it all right
there the action-packed special event
finale tell me you don't understand this
phase of obi-wan kenobi's life without
telling me you don't understand this
phase of obi-wan kenobi's life the
obi-wan kenobi movie i say movie because
as a series it would have been a bit
long-winded but as a movie would have
been great this personal story of this
person who's coming face to face with
the concept of do i actually
believe this thing i just saw my entire
religion get wiped out by my former
friend whom i trained remember that fan
edit that came out a few years ago for
an obi-wan kenobi movie or series i
don't know how it was pitched but it was
a really awesome fan edit it was ewan
mcgregor i think the footage was taken
from a movie where he plays jesus
wandering the desert for 40 days and
fans went nuts for it i went nuts for it
why because the spirit was there because
it should be very comparable instead of
jesus in the desert for 40 days it'll be
one in the desert for a couple decades
it should have been a much smaller story
a more personal story but a story that
could have elevated star wars drama to
the next level and at the very least i
feel like lucasfilm should have taken
that as feedback it's like how are you
gonna be like hey fans are really hyped
for this they really like this fan edit
so we're gonna make an obi-wan series
that is nowhere near the spirit of that
you know what good is data why use it
those are my thoughts on the obi-wan
series it is now done it could have been
so much better and it should have been
so much better all right so the obi-wan
series have you seen it what did you
think about it do you love it do you
hate it are you in the middle we're just
like it's kind of meh i feel like most
people will probably be there regardless
your thoughts comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]
you